[Musique]
dans ce restaurant à quelques pas de la
cuisine les navets côtoie le fenouil ils
attendent patiemment d'être récoltés
pour être cuisiné le jour même c'est
notamment grâce à cette philosophie que
la ruche a été distinguée de l'étoile
verte par le guide Michelin l'étoile
verte c'est donner
récompense des personnes qui font
pratiquement attention à l'environnement
circuit court travaille avec les
producteurs qui respectent
l'environnement éventuellement les gens
qui ont un potager comme nous qui
travaillent qui cultivent leur propre
légumes on fait notre carte en fonction
de ce que l'erreur actuellement ce qui
nous propose donc par exemple l'éleveur
de bovant et il va avoir de temps en
temps des abattages mais ça va être une
date par exemple donc on va partager
avec d'autres chefs de la région et
l'obtention de cette reconnaissance du
guide Michelin a été une véritable de
surprise pour les deux gérants
c'est toujours une distinction
d'une surprise on s'attend pas surtout
ne cherche pas du tout à voir quoi que
ce soit nous on travaille en procurant
nos clients en fait une expérience ce
restaurant situé à Gambais depuis 2019
est composé d'une dizaine d'employés ils
mettent aussi bien la main à la pâte en
cuisine que dans le potager je suis très
contente de cette étoile verte parce que
ça a beaucoup de sens pour moi je
voulais un peu me
décrocher de la gastronomie à la base et
en fait quand j'ai vu cette offre
d'emploi sur un restaurant où il y avait
un vrai respect des produits que ce soit
animal ou végétal ça m'a beaucoup plu ce
côté
on essaye vraiment de travailler le
produit jusqu'au bout le côté jardin le
côté tout ça ça me faisait énormément
cette manière de travailler plus
durablement c'est une évidence pour la
chef américaine
engagement c'est pas nouveau pour moi
j'ai grandi
à San Francisco donc c'est berceau de
l'écurie et correspondibilité donc c'est
quelque chose que j'ai toujours connu on
s'adapter à la nature en fait c'est
notre potager c'est un potager une
permaculture donc il faut vivre avec la
nature et s'adapter à la nature c'est on
s'impose rien donc il y a pas d'intrant
tout est fait avec des endroits naturels
on a par exemple les écuries et les
arafes autour de chez nous et nous
fournissent le fumier par exemple on
peut utiliser ça pour nourrir notre
potager un potager qui s'étend sur une
surface de 2000 mètres carrés et qui est
doté d'une serre ici les sont cultivés
en fonction des saisons donc on a les
épinards des navets on a des fenouilles
des choux des brocolis les
betteraves voilà donc même en plein
hiver on arrive à faire des choses
pas en abondance comme on était mais on
arrive à faire des légumes quand même
sans aucun intermédiaire les produits du
potager sont directement travaillés par
la chef qui propose une cuisine créative
et délicate avec des menus dégustation
allant de 3 à 6 services